Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my flash and the Justice
league saves Christmas video both the comics
are bunch of comic book stories and on the
TV show.
So here we go.
There is a new round of the flash ring giveaway
to all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything during the break so let's
start with the TV show.
Probably the best Christmas story was actually
during season two of the flash where you have
the weather wizard trickster team up where
they basically plant bombs in all the presidents
of all the kids around town to find a creative
way to suck all the bombs simultaneously into
wormhole so that they'll explode elsewhere
and won't hurt anybody is the flash goes down
with a couple really awesome Star Wars Mark
Hamill references and then saves Christmas
or Central city is not time for a real war
on Christmas what is this is a box with
it feels so good to give see the Arrow hundred
random children please take a little box just
like that one Christmas tree is no way she
gets all the fewer look toys
season three didn't really follow up on that
Christmas theme like they did celebrate the
holidays at the end of the episode season
two's episode was more of a straight up Christmas
themed episode because yet Santa Claus at
all the presidents you of the trickster pulling
a joker move and planting bombs all over the
city.
But, on to the comic book stories.
So some of these references, you probably
spot more than others.
Like this Harley Quinn intro with the Charlie
Brown Christmas is totally on the nose very
apropos I totally love this.
She can intros these series of stories.
So in between the one-off stories like you
have Superman saving Christmas you have Batman
saving Christmas you have the flash saving
Christmas.
Those are all separate stories.
The inter-connective tissue is, this Charlie
Brown Christmas with Harley Quinn is kind
of the mouthpiece that involves all the DC
characters hang out together so she says during
this holiday season.
There's one tradition that stands out above
all the others of big spanking holiday special.
So throughout the whole thing.
She drops a bunch of Easter eggs like she
even has a David Bowie being Crosby reference
that I'll explain later her joke right here
is just making fun of the idea of big holiday
special comics in general like some of these
characters have Apsley nothing to do with
each other like she meets the Green Lantern
characters in their like do we do even know
you and she's like nope you never met me before
and they just go on to the next story so just
like you see and Deadpool comics is very self-referential
they like to make fun of themselves when they
do big stories like this that aren't necessarily
part of the canon.
So even though some of these stories like
the Superman one that I'll tell first invoke
a lot of classic Canon this big party that
they're having isn't technically Canon.
So first story Superman of Superboy saves
Christmas is actually a crypto story about
how he's had this really awful year like they
reference the big fight that he had with the
eradicate or earlier in the year that actually
happened during the Superman comic book the
inter-gang storyline they reference here this
is all part of the canon within the Jon can
Superboy, if you know if you haven't been
reading the Superman comic he's named after
Jonathan Kent himself so they just call him
Jon JON Kent.
He has the idea that they need to get crypto
presence of Superman is like right have a
great idea let's go, so he flies into the
Fortress of solitude and shows him the Museum
of artifacts that he houses there like it's
his giant repository for alien artifacts special
things that need to be protected.
He even has an alien zoo for creatures that
are on the endangered species list across
the universe, so Jon get super excited starts
running around like a kid in a candy store
and sees Superman's classic comic book costume
in Superman explains this is the suit that
I met your mother in it was from a long time
ago.
It meant a lot to me.
It was meant to represent my heritage, so
Jon gets a really bright idea that he's going
to use Superman's classic belt and turn it
into crypto's new collar was a really fun
way for them to bring something back from
the classic comics in a really touching way.
So the next story is actually kind of like
Batman ruining Christmas in a very National
Lampoon's Christmas vacation way where everyone's
opening presents Harley Quinn getting really
excited like she got a gift from Superman
here and Batman kind of shies away and wonder
woman makes fun of him did you forget to get
presents for everyone.
He's like just wait a minute wait for it in
everywhere all the characters on their cell
phones get messages that Bruce Wayne has made
a donation in their name to the police retirement
fund, so everyone's like God dammit that is
the worst president ever you ruined Christmas
for us and Batman does his Kermit none of
my business pose here if Mr. Wayne were here.
I'm sure he'd say you're welcome.
So the next story wonder woman kind of explains
what their Christmas traditions are there
holiday traditions on Paradise Island is as
you know we don't really celebrate Christmas
in the traditional sense, but we do dress
someone up who gives us gifts we try to unmask
them that initiates combat the losers are
dressed up in does suits a runoff we hunt
them down like animals thin-skinned them ceremonially
and wrap them up like were baking them in
a giant pastry shell like literally baking
people in pastry shells to just the look on
Harley Quinn face here is priceless.
They panned a Superman and he's kind of like
well I went and my house we just put up a
tree and then wonder woman encounters with
another even more hardcore statement did you
know that the history of Christmas trees are
steeped in validity sacrifice and sorcery,
just reminding you that wonder woman's roots
are that of a warrior.
She's way more hard-core than most of the
Justice league members in the next story is
the flash saving Christmas is flash Christmas
Carol.
So it's not necessarily ghost of past, present
and future there really just borrowing that
name thematically.
It's a much different story just the flash
basically saving Christmas from the roast
but is here visiting one of his friends who
has a foster home, there's a young child who's
really excited about Christmas he tries to
explain what Christmas was like when he was
growing up.
When he was in a foster home himself like
Christmas was very important for me.
Traditions were very important.
I want to make you feel very special in this
holiday time to, so he tries to explain the
concept of Santa.
Santa has a lot of special helpers and then
they panned to the rogues who are in the process
of robbing the bank ho ho ho Merry Christmas
pitches so they have weather wizard creates
no cover, turning it into a white Christmas.
Just bearing the entire area in snow while
there inside the bank.
They almost get some money until the flash
walks in breaking all the glass.
But then surprise surprise Captain.
cold is planted bombs around the city to keep
the flash busy for a couple minutes.
So Captain.
cold knows that the flash is going to be able
to find the bombs get back and Captainure
them.
So in that time he gets one bag of money out
of the bank via mirror master.
While the rest of the rogues try to get the
rest of the hall out via a truck the flash
is able to stop them, but not without Captain.
cold Downing a truck that has a bunch of presents
bound for all these foster children all over
the city so Captain.
cold makes a truce with the flash that he
doesn't want to ruin all these kids Christmases
because Captain.
cold had a terrible childhood.
Barry had a terrible childhood, so sort of
like the hopeful message here is that Captain.
cold is a thief but he has his honor and he
is in a total Dick head.
So he says I will get you after the new year
I'm in a make your life a living hell.
But I'm not gonna ruin Christmas for a bunch
of foster kids.
So he gives the flash of past, the flash is
able to take all the presidents around town
Santa style because the truck that was carrying
them was totaled.
So the flash become Santa Claus for the night
in between all these you have a Rankin Bassett
venture if you guys haven't watched the Rankin
Bass cartoons in a while that's actually fun
to do during the holidays but Rudolph was
one of the big stories.
So in this version of events.
The cold seemed to villains from the DC universe
Captain.
cold killer Frost and Mr. freeze team up to
rob Santa Claus.
But then Harley Quinn rides in on crypto who
takes them down and then because the reindeer
aren't able to fly without some help, let's
them borrow crypto who kind of becomes the
Rudolph of the story leading the sleigh which
is a lot of really fun twist on classic comic
book stories.
Let me know like what is your favorite DC
or Marvel themed holiday story does not to
be Christmas can be any holiday because there
are so many others amended to a couple more
holiday themed comic book videos the Marvel
one actually isn't dropping till next week.
The new Marvel holiday special.
So do a video for that after a post, but there's
a bunch of other Spider-Man Deadpool of avengers
holiday stories.
So the be more of that this weekend so Robbins
made the joke gone so happy holidays everyone
and congratulations to this week's flash ring
giveaway winner Spidey geek please private
message me on the back and my channel so I
can get your contact details.
There was a new round that started in this
video so.
Just announce the winner the next time I post
a DC video so I'll be doing like the ring.
Spider-Man giveaway stuff all week long, just
because the holidays so everybody get height
hopefully open presents tomorrow.
Hopefully we get a Justice league trailer,
really soon to the were still on trailer watch
it could come anytime in the next week so
just be on high alert we just wait for that
to post you can click here for the trailer
for the next episode of the flash and you
can click here for the legends of tomorrow
trailer that you so much watching everybody
thought five I'll see you guys tonight!